my wife and I we're kind of battling the
idea of a few financial decisions um
between paying off our student loans
keep saving to buy a house next year do
we invest more how much do we keep
saving consequently you're not getting
really great traction on any of them
right right yeah lack of focus does that
it disperses the
energy right right and so right now
we're just kind of we have so many
options we're we're doing pretty good
financially um we don't have any debt uh
honey you have student loan debt yeah
besides their student loan debt that's
debt how much student loan debt have you
got 200,000 good God Jesus
Mercy we don't have much debt we're
really doing good I'm only got 200,000
is to that just came out of your mouth
okay okay yeah yeah yeah uh